you're spider-man look next time leave
the fighting to the pros okay but if
there are any around
order in this step
apparently the shows not over
anyone left in New York who doesn't want
me dead
next time you get in my way I will not
be so gentle girl problems again
[Applause]
what is happening to our city hurry
I don't know feels like the end of the
world
maybe it is
Peter Parker how the hell are you
the city is in danger it needs our help
all of our help
alright well I'll call the play coach
costume nutjobs is taking city apart
piece-by-piece time i returned the favor
this is opportunity knocking
you know the closer you get to them the
more you become a target right
the closer I get the better chance we
have to stop them
I've ordered silver sable and our team
to shoot you on sight
this city's had enough of your
vigilantism
you're officially an enemy of the people
Peter
do I call you I mean who would you have
at a cell phone in your in your pot
pockets or something
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man ps4 footage
let's break it down mostly just giving
you an idea for what the story is pretty
early in the game not counting any of
the dlc that they haven't announced yet
but if you're brand new to the channel I
will do a giveaway for the game itself
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video you get a little bit of this early
story where he captures kingpin puts him
behind bars and you hear him complaining
about I'm the real person that keeps
order in this city these are to pay that
off later with that voice over dialogue
where he's talking to Yuri saying what's
happening to our city like things are
slowly crumbling down power abhors a
vacuum so the whole idea is that with
kingpin behind bars
mr. negatives crew called the inner
demons start to take over his former
territory so you've already seen a whole
bunch of footage of that but you do sort
of see Mary Jane on the prow trying to
investigate them like looking through
the doors here and then you also see her
later in Oscorp investigating what looks
like another spider experiment that
might even be where miles gets the
spider bite from because it seems like
when Peter meets him earlier in the game
during that big helicopter save he's
meeting him for the first time and miles
is just a big spider-man fanboy but
somehow it gets roped up in this it
doesn't seem like he has powers when
they're on the stoop here maybe that
happens much later in the story you get
a bunch of new shots of silver sable who
is gunning for spider-man
the voice-over sounds like it's either
the captain of the police or one of the
other villains that's hired silver sable
to take spider-man down but the way they
call spider-man out for being a
vigilante like your days of being a
vigilante in the city are over makes it
sound like it's the Chief of Police
which would normally be Gwen Stacy's dad
I'm loving the Green Goblin teasers that
they give us with all this Oscorp
footage it looks like an older version
of Norman Osborn so I would say he has
parody with Willem Dafoe's Norman Osborn
so I don't think they would leave us
hanging even though we actually haven't
seen him full-on Green Goblin they might
save that for in the last trailers that
they release because they're still about
a month before the game comes out but
remember way back at e3 they released
that special trailer with the rooftop
fight with a newer version of the
sinister six where do them refers to a
mysterious benefactor that wants
spider-man alive that's probably going
to wind up being Norman Osborn
remember he said not to kill him
good idea in fact we don't have to do
this at all if you don't want to we
definitely want
but we also found out that Dr Octopus is
going to be in the game too but we don't
know exactly what is going to be doing
just people saw footage of him he looks
much bigger and more badass than he does
in the comics I think they're just
trying to do a hardcore version of the
character you get some cool footage of
him in the homecoming suit there's a
whole bunch of different suits in the
game they've already shown off the iron
spider costume we haven't seen the
symbiote and for those of you asking
whether or not venom is in the game way
back last year the developers were
ruling him out but then earlier this
summer just a little while ago one of
the developers said there just wasn't
room for him in the game but a lot of
people you know conspiracy theory are
thinking that that's just to
purposefully mislead anyone so that when
the venom movie comes out in early
October they can surprise everyone with
venom DLC that will introduce the
character to the game as well as the
black symbiote costume but in order to
do Peter Parker symbiote within this
game they would have to introduce like a
whole other storyline because right now
it seems like Norman Osborn Oscorp the
sinister six mr- and his inner demons
game are the real main storyline so any
other big spider-man story that they
want to do from the comics like if they
wanted to do the 2099 spider-man costume
that would probably something they would
introduce through a DLC campaign because
even though they're like a billion
different costumes the game does have
ways of explaining why he's wearing it
it does make sense but this is the main
version that you start with
he's about 23 as of the beginning of the
game so he's been through college he's
interning at a lab and the game sort of
picks up with you taking down kingpin
and then everything getting set off from
there there was that really long clip
that they released III I'll link that at
the end of this because you do see a
bunch of the sinister six in that but so
far all we know is is rhino scorpion
electro shocker vulture mr. negative
Doctor Octopus Green Goblin obviously
because we got that Norman Osborn teaser
and taskmaster along with silver sable
who isn't a villain but she's gunning
for spider-man so they're kind of at
odds so you have to view her as a
villain for part of the story but she
might wind up helping him out later in
the game they haven't released a
complete list of all the characters that
they've included but let me know in the
comments which other ones you're hoping
that they include within the MCU though
a lot of you are asking if they're going
to attach the Captain Marvel Trey
to the infinity war blu-ray release I'm
not expecting that but if they do of
course I'll do a video the thing is
though is that that blu-ray is being
released next week so we'll find out in
the next couple of days when they do
drop that trailer Kevin Feige said
pretty quickly after it they'll reveal
the title of Avengers 4 that I am
expecting to see some kind of Avengers 4
footage or a teaser before the end of
the year but remember one thing at a
time Captain Marvel trailer then the
Avengers 4 title then a teaser for
Avengers 4 while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new one punch
season 2 trailer and click here for that
longer spider-man ps4 footage thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]